but what do you think about you know
people like deborah bucks coming out now
and saying they knew all along that you
know they were basically lying about the
the effectiveness of the vaccine i mean
it doesn't isn't doesn't that isn't that
going to wake people up it doesn't seem
to have done actually well i have to
tell you i i see these things and i
often have less of a reaction to them
than other people do because at some
level
i mean i think it's just been obvious
that there is at least a group of people
who have risen to
to the heights of power
who are
uh
very very comfortable with lying look
comfortable at a level that
you have rarely met anyone who could do
it uh you know i mean
fouchy i think is top of this list
that's the sure ease with which he tells
what he must know our fictions is
incredible and so if you imagine that
that's one of the skills that puts you
uh in a position of power uh under our
system then this becomes less surprising
and you know i mean i guess your
question is a good one will it wake
other people up
yeah i hope so um and i i actually think
that
we in the skeptic
community
um
have
misplayed our hand a little bit
because the biological reality
is
you may have
been misled by these people
you may have done things that have
compromised your health but this is
cumulative the sooner you stop listening
to the people who are giving you bad
advice
the better off you will be
and
i'm not telling you who those people are
but i am telling you that we have a
mechanism for knowing who they are and
that mechanism is science which which
means
that
predictive power is the guide right
people who have done a good job of
predicting what was going to happen
those are people worth listening to
could they be lucky
every so often but you can't be
continually lucky right you can't you
can't predict a complex system with a
high degree of accuracy if you don't
have a good model for what's taking
place and if people have predicted
abysmally stop listening to them they're
just they're either they're corrupt or
they're
you know there's a problem you know
there's a problem here again from the
scientific um credibility angle i'll
tell you what it is it's that it's this
whole notion of um peer-reviewed you
know published peer-reviewed papers
right because then they'll say they'll
take what you said right okay well let's
go to let's go to the establishment what
is the established science science what
right you know what are the credit what
are the generally credible sources will
people think well it's the people it's
got to be these peer-reviewed papers
well you know that this whole thing has
been corrupted but again most people
don't interested in this another
interesting about wikipedia here they
will argue that they will only sign and
of course it's all nonsense because they
do it they again do it as they feel fit
they'll change this but they'll they'll
claim that again
they'll reject anything that sort of one
of the skeptics says if it's not
published and you know that you can't
have that that's not an appearance
that's not in a good enough or that's
not in a peer-reviewed journal right
well
it's got to the stage now where um
you know that i mean
forget about the well-known instance
like with you know i mean my colleague
i'm close calling jessica rose and she
had this paper piece of mccullough that
was published but then completely
mysteriously withdrawn and there's a few
other
um examples like that coming out now and
that
sort of made the news where they're
basically trying to get perfectly
respectable
um papers which seriously challenge you
know the safe and effective narrative
they they're getting them they're
getting withdrawn so they won't appear
in uh peer review publications but
but beneath that you've got to think of
the massive stuff you know stuff that
we've done colleagues of mine which
doesn't even get to the stage of being
peer reviewed now if my name now is on a
paper
it will not get it'll be immediately
returned and they won't say because of
my name they'll immediately say it's not
sufficient interest the journal or
but you know it goes well it's worse
than this because you know that they're
the um the
rp um
the you've got these um
pre-print uh servers like med archive
and archive they won't they won't you
know they won't allow my papers either
yep well so this is my name on the list
because they they unlike the one place i
put them is research because there's
absolutely no
screening process there any anyone which
is curious that's actually that's
actually funded by bill and melinda
gates foundation but that's a separate
thing but so far we've been able to put
stuff on research gate right without any
problems and it certainly gets massive
number of reads that papers there but if
i now go to med archive or archive they
have a screening process whether which
they claim
is to they there's obviously some
automated process or whatever which
looks at whether it's in scope or
whatever whether it's whether there's
plagiarism i can understand that because
they can check whether it's a plate you
know whether it's a plagiarized so i can
understand that
right but mine i've always what happens
after three days they'll come back and
say something like out scope this is a
normal one or and that's ridiculous
because no nothing is out it it's
clearly in scope and nothing should get
rejected there so my name
is on is in the screening hours
right and then the the problem is this
cree so
first of all any place that you could
lodge a correct analysis of the evidence
is a threat to whatever it is that is
driving this whatever it is
and therefore
uh if it's the peer-reviewed journals
they will be captured
if it is the pre-print servers then they
will be
manipulated right if it is
a
podcasts then they will be demonetized
and uh
struck from youtube so the basic point
is look you're searching for a venue and
the thing knows that the one thing you
can't be allowed to have is a venue
right
um heather and i have uh said many times
on our podcast
that peer review is not the same thing
as review by peers
that the public has been lured into a
belief that peer review is some sort of
mechanism important to science it is no
such thing any scientist worth their
salt wants their work reviewed by peers
but the system of peer peer review this
secret non-transparent
system is a mechanism of control and it
is not serving science it is serving
power
so
um
the hard part for people to stomach is
that if something is powerful enough i
mean look we know
that pharma manipulates journals that it
manipulates departments that it
manipulates fields we know that it does
that it's well studied
the idea that it
do we think it stops doing that during
covid do we think it's doing it at a
normal level do we think it stepped it
up we never have that conversation we
simply pretend that it's on the same
team trying to cure covet as the rest of
us yeah and at the point you recognize
that
the
major
medical associations that
most doctors that most
all universities as far as i know
that the major journals that all of
these things have landed on a team
that team has a narrative
you as a member of the public can know
that that team is spouting nonsense i
mean
let's put it this way
if effective
means you need four doses in less than
two years and it still doesn't control
contraction or transmission of the
disease if that's what effective means
what a safe mean
right
right effective obviously doesn't mean
effective i'm thinking safe might not
mean safe either so at the point you
realize somebody's telling me oh yeah
this is safe you should get it and that
person will
you know they didn't do very well with
effective and i can tell that myself
because i'm being told i need my fourth
dose right at that point
i'm not saying this is a good thing but
i am saying at that point you should
stop listening to the people who told
you it was effective because they were
wrong they have not acknowledged that
they were wrong they haven't explained
how that happened or what you should
think now right you should not listen to
them and you should say well
it would be great if there were an
institution or a publication i could go
to
that would tell me the truth
doesn't exist so
maybe i should start looking around for
people who have left a record of what
they've thought over the course of the
pandemic and i should start looking for
people for whom that record suggests
that they do understand what's going on
right that's very difficult to find is
you know you go on a google search and
you're not going to be if you search for
you know your name you'll get to just
you know you'll get the decision you'll
find out that i'm a notorious spreader
of misdis and male information
um
i mean the whole the way i mean this is
another thing we haven't touched on but
i mean and you've of course your own
experience uh you know
bears this out even before covert is
that is the
is that is how academia which you know
was traditionally supposed to be you
know all about free speech you know
progressive standing up for i mean you
know you know standing up for the
disadvantaged and and confronting the
you know big tech and big i mean how are
they suddenly how have they
i mean it was happening before covert
but with covert especially how they
suddenly been completely almost done i
would say 99
captured even
they've just totally
been in this sort of you know this this
this
you know
this this narrative of we have to have
control we have to we have to censor
anybody who disagrees with them we've
got to ostracize those people we've got
to humiliate them i mean where is the
traditional academic you know
progressive liberal ideals and always
it's completely banished
right and and
in parallel where is the hippocratic
oath
exactly for the clinicians yep that that
seems to have gone out the window yeah
right so so you know i used to say back
before covid
when people would ask me about
academia and what we could do to save it
and my feeling is well a
some of us have been shouting about this
for decades this is not a new problem
and the fact that it is now so
uh clear that everybody can see it
doesn't mean you know this is now the
point of you know you've had coveted for
a week and you want to know what to do
about it the answer is well you should
have started treating it on day one same
thing for academia now
we have to switch analogies here a
little bit but the basic point is look
academia is like
your family dog after it's contracted
rabies
right the right way to think about it is
not that's the family dog the right way
to think about it is oh my god that
animal has rabies
right and
you're gonna need you're gonna need a
new dog and that other dog has to go and
um i don't know you know i would not
have let the situation get there but
we're there and it doesn't make any
sense to pretend otherwise but it's
clearly
totally captured and yeah i mean look
what happened to you evergreens i mean
that was you know that's nothing i mean
that's happened that that's you know
that that kind of thing is
you know is is happening to a lot of
people i mean you know that i
i've never ever had a complaint about my
teaching anywhere until this whole thing
started and this you know
before i even you know before i even
gave my you know
i did this masters module but to a big
class at 260 students or so
a group of students you know
went to the head of school and said you
know we're not going to be we refuse to
be taught by this misinformation
anti-vaxx anti-vaxxer guide even though
it's a compulsory module we demand to be
moved to another another module i mean
i've never you could never believe this
happened and and the fact that i don't
get supported by you know the
the students are the ones who
who you know apparently are in the right
to be concerned about this you know the
lack of support the lack of support i
mean not just that but
the lack of support for you know what
you know the kind of
nonsense i've had to put up with
throughout this has been
it's it's just it's remarkable how this
you just realize that there's nobody in
equity you've got a few
close colleagues who you trust right but
beyond that you you absolutely know that
you're not going to get any support
you know from anyone you get well it's
interesting
especially with this subject because
although you know a lot of the stuff
that we do
is you know does have the sort of
complex bayesian stuff but actually
most of the data analysts the most stuff
we've been revealing anyone with you
know with a sort of basic understanding
of statistics you know you know school
you know you know not even high school
level but just basic statistics will
know could point out the problems yeah
and yet where are the step where are the
where are the top statisticians and
other mathematicians standing up right
absolutely absolutely silent or actually
criticizing us right which which has to
be based in fear
right yes i've had you know that i have
had i have had a small number of very
very senior very very um you know top
rated statisticians contact me privately
and say
they understand they support it but they
can't speak out to be the end of their
careers i mean i can only really do it
because i'm i'm you know i'm a
retirement age it would be different it
would have been difficult for me so i
would probably have been just as much
a coward as
then you know if this was you know if
this was 15 years ago i don't know
well this is this is why i i don't hold
back with the analogies like
rabies
right the point is look
yeah i'm not it's not a good thing that
your dog has rabies but you know
rationalizing about it is going to make
things much worse yeah right so yeah i i
don't know
i'm shocked i'm as shocked as i am at
academics i'm even more shocked by the
doctors
yeah yeah
right this is basic nuremberg uh
hippocratic oath stuff
and the thing is but lots of them it's
it's like they've not taken it's not
that they know that they're doing wrong
they don't it's just that they they are
simply
getting the mainstream information
they're not attempting to find out
themselves okay but i've challenged
doctors on this who are you know you
know yeah you're getting another science
guy okay here's my contention you're
right the doctors do not know they are
doing harm but
that is on
the user's side in other words the
amount of work the doctors have to do to
avoid the information that they're doing
harm is substantial
so
i i really think
whatever it is that we are up against
whatever is spreading the real
uh misinformation and advancing this
incredibly wrong-headed narrative
that thing smartest thing it ever did
was
force the hand of the doctors early
right because the point is
to
to revert to recognize what is taking
place
also means to acknowledge the harm
you've participated in already and i
think that's a very
uh
high bar and i i'm still shocked that
doctors aren't crossing it in large
numbers
but um but nonetheless it does
i think it is easier to double down on
yeah yeah no you're absolutely i think
you're right yeah you're right on that
no doubt about it yeah
yeah it's it's really it's really tragic
but nonetheless here we are
it's 2022
our institutions have i mean look they
were captured now the degree to which
they were captured is revealed to us if
we will simply look at it and everything
from uh medicine to academia
to wikipedia all of these things are
mainstream medicals mainstream media
maybe went first but yeah yeah it's
catching it across
well academia the rot began probably in
academia certainly in the 90s we saw
hints of it i think i think it was stuff
before then
oh well that may be i certainly saw it
in the 90s in college yeah um
but in any case yes all of the
institutions are infected by this
particular
uh pathology and
the danger to us couldn't be greater so
as unpleasant as it is to look that
reality in the eye it's far safer than
ignoring it for another who knows how
long yeah this isn't going to get better
until we look at it
[Music]
you